the Turkish military is pushing deeper
into northern Syria this morning and
it's massive offensive against Kurdish
allies of the United States Turkey
accuses the Kurds of being terrorists a
human rights group says at least 16
people have been killed and 33 wounded
in the assault so far Turkish forces
attacked by land and air after US troops
in the region pulled back from their
positions near the Syrian border
President Trump who agreed to withdraw
those troops is now calling the Turkish
attack quote a bad idea Charlie d'Agata
is in northern Syria this morning he has
reported extensively from the region
well we just crossed that River from
Iraq to here in northern Syria it's a
crossing we've made several times in the
past year but this time it's different
the Kurdish forces who we've accompanied
in their fight against Isis are now
under attack themselves from a US and
NATO ally the Turkish military unleashed
an onslaught of artillery and air
strikes overnight targeting tilapia and
Syrian town of Rasul ie both recently
vacated by US forces and that's not all
the Turkish Defense Ministry say they
struck a hundred eighty so-called
terrorist targets across a hundred fifty
miles span that includes key cities of
Qamishli and kobani and they say a
ground offensive has begun today it is
already underway now commanders of the
Kurdish led Syrian democratic forces say
they've had to put a pause on operations
against Isis in order to face down this
Turkish invasion they also say the
offensive has jeopardized the security
of prisons housing thousands of Isis
prisoners risking a breakout or possibly
leading to an Isis resurgence now the
military action the past 24 hours has
sparked a mass exodus of thousands of
civilians who are trying to flee the
reach of Turkish artillery and air
strikes and
SDF has warned of a humanitarian
catastrophe if this Turkish offensive
continues at this intensity and I can
tell you we've spent years with these
SDF forces watching them from the
frontlines in their fight against Isis
men and women who've helped protect us
they say that they were broadsided by
what happened they feel abandoned and
betrayed Charlie d'Agata reporting from
northern Syria thank you